good morning good evening depending upon
where you are in the world um
okay so let's get started for those of
you who have been doing my sessions you
know uh like you know how i go about my
sessions usually
i have this cheat sheet over here
basically i used to you know run by the
content which i'm going to be telling
you about in some time and then i also
use this as a as a sheet to uh you know
write my destinations or or
or the concept that i'd be explaining to
you and what i do is you know one by one
i keep
completing the content and keep marking
it over here so just like uh now for
example richard has completed my
introduction so i'll just come here and
say done and i'll keep marking you know
other things also like this has done
so that's what it is that is how i'm
going to be
going about this session so that's one
part second part is that let me just
quickly run you through uh you know the
structure of this presentation how i'm
going to be going about it uh basically
since this is about three steps to your
dream big data role i'm gonna be telling
you about three steps uh
uh as to you know what all technologies
what all frameworks what all software um
you know you should invest your time in
uh so that you can land up ultimately
into you know that kind of you know job
or role so one of the first step if you
see over here is about you know some big
data technology uh you know called this
hadoop the second step is about uh
about a little bit about spark because
that's something which is which has
picked up
you know quite uh quite big time in the
last or i would say an year or so and
the third is about
you know a bit about
statistics and data science
uh so um you know i'm going to be you
know telling you about that so so that's
what the structure of my presentation uh
you know i usually tell the structure as
well so that you have an idea as to
where we are starting and and you know
where we'll be ending up in you know
these uh uh these uh
you know i would say
give me one second
uh in next next you know 45 minutes or
so
anyways so we are let's get started uh
with that
with that context being said um
so
before you know everything else let's
first start uh let's first understand
you know what is big data formal
definition to big data
uh the other day uh one gentleman i
think it was one of my attendees in one
of my batches uh was asking me you say
that big data is you you say big data is
big how busy big is big
where does the
show when does the game begins can you
tell me how big is big
so i asked him
tell me
excuse me
tell me what is the hardest size uh you
know of the computer that you use
he said i have a laptop which has a one
terabyte of hard disk and i've got a
desktop which has got four terabyte
developers i said amazing
any data
any data which your laptop or your
desktop cannot store
conveniently
comfortably
that data is big data
any data which your machines which your
individual machine which
single machine that you work upon are
not able to store it forget about
processing it
the first question it comes in is to
storing it
right any data that your individual
machine cannot
comfortably store it
is big data
so i am talking about size i am talking
about volume i am talking about the
sheer humongous size of the data
where
storage itself becomes a challenge
and that and the challenge
is welcomed by everyone
because everyone knows that if this is
the challenge which they can overcome
right and
analyze this data process this data
so that they can get some meaningful
insight out of it
they can have
advantages over their competitors
right advantages over their competitors
so storage is a challenge right before i
tell you about these challenges let me
just formally uh and tell you the
definition of big data as i have written
over here
for you
according to american iit research
advisory firm
gartner big data is high volume
high velocity and high variety
information asset
high volume right huge data humongous
data
high velocity data coming at huge speed
like
you know something like if you would
have seen your lock servers you know how
they get started you know they get
started very very they get started and
they start generating logs and you know
breadth taking speed suppose somebody
asks you to analyze that log
right log aggregation that is a feedback
study on its own
that is that is high velocity suppose a
server like twitter or a server like
facebook or application like facebook
application like twitter application
like flipkart
has started and decided to stream the
data
that is high velocity data that is data
which is like constantly coming you have
a need to capture that data and then
store it so that you can analyze it
right so high velocity and then high
variety information right it is not only
text it could be image it could be
binary it could be audio it could be
video you name it
right it could be of different different
forms
right it is that kind of information i
said that demands cost effective
right till now we have been using
traditional systems which are very very
costly
think about those ibm servers and those
sensor other servers running into lags
and crores
of rupees
right
it demands a cost effective innovative
form of information processing
that enable enhance insight so that you
can
you can you can take decisions which
becomes game changer for your business
right which becomes game changer for
your business
right and then you create processes
using big data technologies
which basically automates everything
and there are these various various
different components
which are present for each every you
know word that i have you know kind of
you know emboldened here for you
for process of automation there is a big
data framework called as apache oozy
which automates your processing of data
right for high volume data storage
there's something called as hdfs which
we'll know in some time
for processing we've got something
called as map reduce which we'll know in
some time
right process automation
so this is the you know quick
introduction to big data i would say
challenges with respect to big data
storage is one thing that you know i
have spoken about right isn't it storage
is a problem
a story is a challenge right the another
problem is obviously you want to do
business analytics right the other
problem is processing that formation
how to process that information that
itself is also a challenge
itself is also a challenge let's see if
there is we have any technology
available
which basically meets these challenges
provides solution to these challenges do
we have it or do we not
let's find out let's go and find out
this definition of this software called
as hadoop
right hadoop definition
quickly
apache hoop is an open source framework
meant to provide an automated
distributed computing environment
it is an open source framework right
open source
frameworks open source
softwares are the softwares
which have certain characteristics
number one they are free of cost
number two they are
they are uh you know they have a huge
community base
huge community base
right
where you kind of just come across a
problem somebody will be there to solve
it
and framework framework framework are
those
repetitive activities which are actually
not business logic not business
analytics but it is something that you
anyway have to do something like
security framework logging framework
transaction framework right if you talk
about technology database connection
framework like jdbc
web services framework many of them
so it's that kind of open source
framework what is it
provides an automated distributed
computing
environment right so if you work on
distributed computing you would know
that working in distributed computing
manually is a pain
one of the machine going down
right the other machine
will have to be brought into rotation
it's it it's basically a very cumbersome
time taking an error error process
what hadoop says is that i will
provide the
solution
i will provide an automated distributed
computing environment
where if your machines are going down i
will make sure that i will replace the
bad machine with a good machine
i will do that
right
also it provides solution to this about
two problems by way of these two things
number one is hadoop distributed file
system it gives something called as hdfs
hadoop distributed file system
right which is a which is a which is an
amazing storage mechanism
and it provides something called as
mapreduce
which is a processing framework
right so storage was a challenge
made by hadoop using hdfs
mapreduce processing was a challenge
made by hadoop using mapreduce as a
solution
so to
us
to challenge this game in front of you
because of big data storage and
processing those two challenges are
salt are met by
a technology called as hadoop
apache hadoop
now that's how that's why they say that
pati hadoop is something which is
married to big data
it shines when you throw big data at it
it shines
and as you know the data around us is
becoming huge and huge i mean if i ask
all of you all you would have definitely
like you know each one of you would
possess at least a 500 uh you know
terabyte of hard disk
500 500 gb of hardness to save your data
right and you would have your you know
the movies and then your resumes and
your and your you know your your
softwares and what whatnot your projects
and whatnot
that is data like at individual capacity
imagine how much data the uh you know
the uh the organizations and and and you
know corporates will be generating
so this is what it is challenges with
respect to big data quickly um you know
apache hadoop solution
uh
what i'll do is with this brief
definition of in hadoop what i'm going
to do is that i'm going to you know run
one sample program for you to tell you
how the program looks like how the
program runs like so just come here i'll
show you the software this is the
software you know running on my local
machine
right
and
you know you can see all these software
demons running right when you join my
class i kind of you know in detail in
depth go through uh you know these uh
these concepts on you know what are
demons and what
you know what is what over here
so so these are all the payments these
are all the software demands which you
know run for you in your uh you know in
which you are running for me in my in my
uh you know in my local uh these are
some of the um you know
the uh the commands
uh what you call uh you know hdfs
commands
if i do hadoop fsls it basically is
going to show me
the
the output of hdfs what i can do is that
i can say
rm r slash output it will delete my
output further
right i'll quickly go and you know do a
sample job run for you
right that's how the job looks like
right that's all the job look like so
the job will run the mappers will run
the reducers will run and it will
basically this is basically a canonical
uh word count program that i'm trying to
kind of you know run over here for you
um
uh so so while the job is running uh i
would like to see the mapper has uh
started running zero percent the reduce
will run zero percent and then uh and
then uh and then mapper will become
hundred percent reduce it with a hundred
percent and so on and so forth like that
right so this is a you know canonical uh
you know word count program that that
that we have done you know how to sample
them you can do the same program on a
big data file so so i have if i go to
this
i can see loop f is ls
um
i can see over here that there is a 1 gb
file
i can run my same program on a 1gb file
as well
right so
what i'll say is that uh you know i'll
just i'll just you know kind of you know
delete the output again here and then
while running the program i'll just say
instead of test.txt lc5.txt
what do you say
and this program will run it will keep
running on and on and on and on so um
the point over here is that you know
after running um you know running this
program for you let the program run let
me come back to the content here
the point over here is that number step
number one in order for you to move
towards your you know that big data
dream job you have to learn
right you have to learn hadoop
you have to learn how to there is no
getting away from that
by is
a software which is both which is made
in java
so you will have to have some kind of
java background as well when you join
you know our course basically give you
some java modules along with um you know
i have some some some java slides
prepared you know with with with it it's
code up and running for you to
kind of you know practice and become
proficient in it
right so this is the job running like
you know it will take some three minutes
to done so that is the first thing that
you do now in hadoop there are so many
things which are there hadoop itself
hdfs which is part of hadoop job runs
which we have done just now and then no
sql databases right
hadoop runs in a batch-oriented manner
hadoop runs in a maturated manner you
know it cannot be plugged behind your
rdbms because it's batch oriented but if
somebody wants to access big data on a
real-time basis that is where
no sql database is coming and no sql
databases are there are various
categories of it
there is a nosql database which is based
on uh which is based on google one
google white paper called as google big
table white paper
right it is called as edge you know the
the that category is called as uh no sql
database base is based on big table good
white paper so hbs and cassandra are
those databases
right mongodb you would have definitely
heard about it you should learn mongodb
as well very you know excellent courses
available on the web which can
by the way you know you know help you
understand it so that is the first thing
that you should do
the second thing that you should do my
friend is that you should you should
basically learn spark
now
before telling you about spark let me
just give you a bit of background as to
why spark and why
spark has come into picture now if you
could in a slight idea about hadoop you
would know that in hadoop
there is a process called as shuffle and
sort members run members do a dump on
the individual machine on which
the uh on which the uh you know the the
mappers are running and then from there
shuffle and sort mechanism picks up
and then delivers the machine on which
the reducer is running so there's a
whole lot of data getting dumped on the
you know machines uh on which the
mappers are running and and then you
know reducer processing
now that actually writing something on
the machine is basically a performance
intensive exercise
right
has been doing very well in the last uh
you know three four years it is probably
it has probably has the penetration also
right now in the industry um where
people are using it quite prolifically
but then there is a need
for faster analytics where
you know these processing units don't
have to dump data on the individual
machines
right they don't have to dump data on
the on the machines
you know these jobs can do in memory
computations and then basically do the
final output on on any storage mechanism
hdfs or any storage mechanism of yours
right so
the need for real time faster analytics
again in batch oriented mode
is where spark comes into the picture
right so that is the step two that i
would like to tell you my friends right
that is the step two that i would like
to tell you learn spark
because it is going to it is going to
keep you relevant for at least next to
three years i would say right let's
start now spar with that background what
is the formal definition of spark let's
go ahead and understand it
let's come to the next page
apache again it's a party product it's a
fast and general purpose clustered
computing
system it is order of magnitude faster
than normal use
in fact in you know in in latest
versions of hadoop especially of
commercial softwares mapreduce is
getting slowly and slowly replaced by
spark
right so it is a
fast lithium emboldening and provides so
so it is a cluster computing platform
just like
hadoop and mapreduce but it it is faster
right it provides high level apis in
java scala python and r it provides you
not one but four interfaces one of them
will see
like javascript
you can use any that you are comfortable
with and an optimized engine that
supports general execution graphs you
would have heard about this term called
as dags direct a secret a cyclical
nickel graphs
so what it does is that when you put the
data inside spark it basically creates
and creates a dags
right of the jobs of the tasks in the
cluster and then run them one by one
right then one by one and without
dumping an intermediate data onto the
disk on which the
task is admitted
so so apart from it having those core uh
you know those core
core api uh you know
core api libraries it also has got some
rich high level tools
to give you specialized
frameworks like a spark sql where you
can deal with big data in a sql fashion
right
emblem for machine learning
right streaming for the streaming data
like i was telling you about log
processing and graphics
for processing of data which is getting
generated from let's say you know graph
graph based data like so data that you
get from social networking
right so
so um that is what you can do you can
you know basically uh you know learn
spar that is the formal definition of uh
spark right over here for you um
let me just show you uh spark and you
know how it looks like um i'll kind of
you know quickly tell you uh so this is
core spark over here spark code in
between uh
if on top you go you can see all these
specialized interfaces these rich tools
like spark sql sparks streaming mlib
graphics and below over here you can see
these
resource managers now if you know about
hadoop you would know that hadoop has
got a resource manager here you've got
three options of resource manager yan
which is hadoop's resource manager
vsauce which is another apache very uh
like you know popular
resource manager and spark's own
resource manager called as
a standalone scheduler give me one
minute i'll just have some water
spark's own
scheduler called as
standalone scheduler
right a standalone scheduler so so this
is what it is now
uh
this is done yeah how's art works and
quickly i'll just quickly give you an
idea and you know at that time i think
it becomes prudence it becomes prudent
for me to also show you
something very interesting and uh you
know that is about my uh you know about
about my blog so i'll usually write
you know this blog i keep getting keep
you know updating it as well
if you uh you know go through this
section on my blog
let me just show it to you uh where is
it
uh similarities and differences between
uh there you are similarity the
differences between hadoop and spark
architectures
right let me let me kind of you know
tell you about this so i i would also
share this blog link with all of you all
on my chat window so that everyone has
it
uh
and
and then basically i'll just go you know
go one by one
yeah
so as uh you know you would know in
hadoop
you've got you know something called as
you know something called as driver
class
something called as driver class so in
spark you also have got
you know a driver class but it is
context
right it is called a spar context and it
looks like this over here let me show
this to you in a graphic also but i'm
explaining this from my blog right so
you've got a spark context over here
right one difference between spark and
map reduce and hadoop is that a spark
gives you shelves
as i was mentioning your definition it
gives you shelves and scala is giving
this give you shells in python
macroblue does not give you a shell
when you have a shell it becomes easier
for you to proof test your programs
right
so so this is what is so this is a smart
context over here in between you've got
something called as uh
give me one second uh
you've got you know something called as
uh
as a cluster manager
right and there are three flavors of
cluster manager you've got
you know you've got you've got yarn
you've got me sauce and you've got uh
you've got you've got sparks download
and by the way
let me see yeah my job is over
yes
um yeah my job is over on a 1gb file so
yes crack claps
okay so um anyways so
so that's what it is so um
yeah so
so there you are so you've got cluster
manager and then just like just like spa
just like you know you know mac reduce
macro in my previous you've got master
nodes and your slave nodes here you've
got something called as worker nodes
right so you can see worker nodes over
here and mapreduce has got something
called as containers here you've got the
same things known as executors
that is the runtime which provides you
the jvm
right and mapreduce have got mappers and
reducers here you've got something
called as task it can be another it can
be a reducer
right so that's how you know um
you know spark works
if you see my blog the last line it says
that
you know how does it work
now this base path works is through
spark context via underlying cluster
manager whichever
you know personal manager is there of
your choice
you get hold of executed processes for
sparks spark jobs to run so you submit
the job from here
and you get hold of all these executable
process
and then these executable processes gets
in touch with hdfs to get the block of
data
and then run these tasks which could be
mappers or reducers in memory without
having the need to do the dump on the
machine on which these tasks the terms
is done in the end and when
the this job returns you get the and you
know you have the option of giving doing
the dump either on the hdfs or giving
the value back to the spark context you
yourselves
to you yourself
right so this is what so what i would
urge you guys is to kind of you know go
through uh this post in detail whatever
i've just explained to you right now uh
is is what is given uh in this uh you
know in this uh
in this
block right so
going back to this here i think this is
also being done now spark is about
something called as rdds concept called
as rdds
and rdd in spark is simply an immutable
distributed collection of objects
right so rdd basically represents data
and computation
in in hadoop data is hdfs computation is
mapreduce in
in spark rdd is both data as well as
computation right there's a common
abstraction
right and you have when you're creating
the rdds you have the options of
defining how many blocks here it is
called as partitions to divide your data
into
right and you can and then your cluster
manager decides which worker node your
partitions will go and store the data
and compute do the computations right so
spar and rdd in spar is simply an
immutable distributed collection of
objects
each rdd is
is split into multiple partitions
depending upon how you have defined your
partitions
okay so you have the options of defining
your partitions on your own
and which may be computed on different
nodes because your underlying cluster
manager is going to decide for you
where on your worker nodes these
these these these tasks will get
executed
right rdds can be written in any
language
python javascript nr and your own rdds
as well
there are two types of arguments
transformations
and actions
transformation basically load the data
and create new new add new loaded
idds from the previous rdds actions
represent
basically give you back the results
so action is the mapreduce part
transformation is the hdfs part that's
how you can you know make the enlarge my
friends
right so why don't we do this why don't
we go into this one of the shells and
you know run you know it's run some
program and so i've done this quickly
and this quickly and this also quickly
why don't we go ahead and run you know
some programs so there you are
let me go ahead and start a spark shelf
right let us start a spark shell it will
take a while uh you know to get started
uh in the meantime uh yeah let me get
started and you can if you have a mac
machine you can do the installation and
by the way doing the installation of
spark is also there on my on my blog i'm
doing the
you know instructions
the structures for doing the hadoop
installation are also there on my blog i
urge you guys to can go through them and
and you know kind of you know use it for
for your own like you know for your own
convenience and benefit right so so
that's there now i'm just waiting for
this shell to get started um
interesting uh some of the interesting
post in my blog is uh i'll tell you one
of the most popular posts is uh
is a single node uh installation and
hadoop signal installation uh another
popular pose is uh hadoop multi-node
installation so you know a multi-node
installation in hadoop looks like this
uh multi-node installation over here um
you know i can i can run it
i won't be able to do it now because of
the scarcity of time but you can
definitely run it uh i usually do it in
my class in my sessions
so if you you know pick up you know
something like this
you know so if i come here in hdfs what
you can see is uh you know
in my normal terminal what you can see
is if i say ls minus l i can see a file
here test
right this is a wonderful wonderful
wonderful session which it which it is
isn't it
uh so i can come here and load the same
file you know from here i can say kadak
text file
it will load the data so basically this
operation is creating an audience
right i could have given the option as
to how in multiple partitions of blocks
it can you know divide
and then over this i can run multiple
actions
so something like
what do you say count
right count is going to give me the
number of lines it has got only one line
it will give me one line
uh
what do you say it's
something like a first
you basically if you give you the uh you
know first line this is a multiple
session right something like this
now let's do one thing uh
uh let's let's try and run our word
count program over here in spark why
don't you do that now in order for me to
do that i have to first of all you know
tell you a couple of things in spark
itself right the first thing that i am
going to tell you is you know uh is is a
transformation called as flat map the
details of it is written in the in this
block i urge you guys to you know go
through it
there's something called as flat map it
basically
does the
does the operation of string tokenizer
if if if you if you know java right so
basically
create the words and
you know create take a line take a
string of line and then divide them into
you know individual words and then flat
out
all the output we'll see an example of
it let's say i have got this as an input
isn't it
and say i've got this as an input
uh
there you are
right there's something called as
parallelized method where you can give
your sample data
in the previous example i loaded the
data from the local host
right here i am loading the data from a
parallelized method which can where you
can give sample data this is good for
practice not for production or
development
i say enter
it is creating an rdt for me over here
and then i will apply
a flat map
transformation over here now the
characteristic of this black map
transformation is that it basically
takes function as a
parameter
right if you know scala if you've got
some idea about scala you know that
scala is a language which improves upon
java and scholars the world where
objectivism where object oriented
programming meets functional programming
this is an example on a scholarship
right what i'm saying is that in flat
map just tokenize
words by space
i'll enter it and i'll say word dot
y dot collect collect is the action over
here when i say this it basically is
going to give me these words
simple very simple this quickly we'll
see another uh you know transformation
over here uh called as map
map basically
is
does the same thing what a mapper does
in your maps
right so again we load some data
that's again we will go ahead and load
some data and do a mapping for it
what is it
all right so i'll say paste i'll say um
yeah parallels
i got created i'll use map on top of it
i'll say
it basically it does as something called
a segregation when you do when i when i
you know take my sessions i usually say
that math
is an element of three parts
segregation assimilation aggregation
segregation is mapper assimilation is
shuffle and sort
aggregation is reducer so what is what
map is doing over here is that it is
doing segregation it is segregating
these individual words and marking them
as one
as the function is given let's see the
output of it
with collect action
here everything is marked as one which
is fine which is great which is what we
wanted isn't it
right
there is a third
action called as count by key
it basically does a count of the key
right so if you see this over here
example example is repeated but it has
not been aggregated if you on top of it
use something called as count
by
key
what you will see is that
kadak
your similar words will get
summed up
right so why don't we do this why don't
we combine these transformations and
actions into one and find out word count
of our text file why don't we do that
why don't we do that why don't we do
that let's do that let us declare our
text file again
right and let's chain all these
lines over here
yeah flat map
space map word by one and count by key
correct
right so you've got is this one this is
one wonderful as three because three was
um you know
repeating three times and then you've
got session
so that's how you can write word count
spark
right that's how you can write word
conspire
now
so i hope uh you guys got an idea about
how important and essential it is for
you to you know learn spark and and make
the most of it now um and the third part
and the third step and the last step is
that
i would say data science and statistics
you know i'm sure you would have like
you know then you know your geometric
relation and intermediate and you know
if those of you done majors in
statistics and maths you would have
definitely come across lots and lots of
parts and graphs
and if you work in excel you come across
things like you know the bar charts and
histograms and plots and you know all
those kind of things these have become
so essential so useful so mandatory so
important
that i cannot pay more emphasis
right statistics at the very elementary
level starting from a very unique what
is the mean what is mode what is median
what are measures of central tendency
what are measures of dispersions
what is p value
right i i i can you know talk about all
this because i've done my majors and
statistics but it's not different
difficult i tell you
it's not difficult statistics is one
thing which becomes basically helps you
visualizing the data
processing and doing business analytics
is one but then
showing it to your end business to your
end user in a nice jazzy
visual representation
is a different ball game altogether
and it's a circle if you think about it
like if you really want to think about
it it's a circle the game starts at the
data science level where your data
scientists are going to be you know
really um you know turning the data
finding out those you know areas where
they can uh you know really mine through
the areas which will look potentially
you know
is to explore and then going to the
business entering the business that this
is the area that we should look in
and then business taking a call and then
business telling the uh you know big
data team to uh kind of you know do the
implementation and then those
implementations are again coming back to
these status in the data science team
which is like making a nice
jazzy tabular and graphical
representation and presenting it to the
business
that's why you need statistics and data
science right
uh one of the most important uh
you know languages that you would
like you know come across in statistics
and which i would like you know highly
or recommend you to learn is uh
is something called as uh
uh is something called as
r
um i don't have any scripts you know you
know handy for you to you know show it
to you but you know if there is one
language that you know i would recommend
you to
you know learn in hadoop
in in in you know in
for you to like to make
do well in the industry and line up with
that job is to learn r
right r has got this
it's basically a data visualization
platform it's very simple very easy to
use based on statistics and has got
wonderful community support
right um
similar has got good our courses uh you
know i've done at one point of time uh
those specializations offers by coursera
uh eight or nine of them which i have
completed on my own
by whatever ways or means whichever you
find comfortable and get fascinated with
learn r
might learn r there's another software
called as tableau uh which is more of uh
you know i would say you know commercial
software so i wouldn't recommend it that
much but statistics and are
for you to venture into the space of
data science
is what i would recommend guys and the
reason why i say this is because you
know people come to me and ask me
questions guys and you know do i need to
uh
learn hadoop do i need to uh like you
know i am i am an admin so can i just
get away with
learning you know how to configure
software
do i need to learn programming languages
do i need to think about visualization
you know do i need to go to that extent
yes
you should
i am telling this to you from my
personal experience
i i have a lot of clients all across the
world
i keep going to you know to meet these
clients when i sit with these clients
right and they tell me whatever money
that they are paying me what they tell
me is that look i am i am paying you i'm
paying you money you do everything
right you are the developer you are the
administrator you are the visualizer
there are three or four people in the
team you do everything you are one stop
shop solution for me
that's why i have hired you to do
everything for me
right so what are the days where people
used to look for niche
skills
companies organizations used to look for
niche skills
organizations nowadays need people's
need resources who know everything
who know everything all the areas and
they are they have a tendency of
learning more
right so
i usually you know spend a lot of time
on this uh in my you know in my in my
batches i'm not going to spend more time
on this but this is uh you know what uh
what what is the message from from my
side spark hadoop
statistics and data science
that is the you know way to go for you
guys
right i'm done richard are you there
yes i am sayad thank you that was a
wonderful talk i enjoyed that immensely
uh we have some great questions you're
welcome i uh richard i can't i cannot
see the questions uh it's something you
have to enable
um you know it's a way they switched it
um i don't have a way of letting you see
the questions direct i think they
because they want us to go ahead and uh
make sure that we go through the
questions and
um filter them out for you uh okay that
would be that would be great
yeah so i'll look into that i'll look
into that
i'm gonna go ahead and i have a couple
things i'm going to do one i'm going to
take over your screen for just about
five minutes while we do that while we
start the qa
and set up a poll that i have going for
from simply learn
just go ahead and launch that and you'll
see that coming up there
and then we'll go and start that we have
some great questions on here uh that
cover all kinds of different things
there's kind of a trend and i'm going to
start with the general question uh we
have the hadoop file system and of
course we have uh hive for the sql and
the hbase and the different setups of
map and reduce and then we have spark
that's coming in and a lot of people are
asking hey is spark
hbase or spark replacing pieces of
hadoop or mapreduce what how does spark
and hadoop interface with each other
what what's the role that spark plays
with the hadoop file system
oh okay so i i mentioned about this a
bit in my presentation also see hadoop
has got two parts uh one is hdfs and the
other one is mapreduce hdfs is a great
solution for storing big data but but
mac reduce has you know
it's as it is turning out has certain
limitations um you know so it does these
intermediate uh you know output on the
map mapper machines because of it it
becomes uh you know
uh you know performance inefficient so
what is you know if the way i have seen
the trend in the industry right now uh
result is that uh you know slowly and
slowly these commercial players in
hadoop like um
like cloud era like map are like
hortonworks they are replacing uh map
only map reduce part of hadoop by spark
so they if you go to cloudera website
also uh richard what you will see
is that uh now they offer a
certification in hadoop and spark
and they have replaced mapreduce part
of hadoop by spark
uh so you know i would answer this in
two way map hadoop hadoop would remain
but only from the point of view of the
storage of big data hdfs um map reduce
will you know slowly get phased out and
it is going to get replaced by spark
even in the raw you know hdfs so i would
say you know going forward in hadoop
hdfs is the way to go
uh and then you know you want to spark
and start in a learning spark that is
the message from my site
okay excellent
yeah that that's uh that is that that
seems like where the the market's going
on there
we have a
more technical question um
the question is is if you have a
this comes from
i think the screen just popped up funny
hold on one second i got to fix that
real quick
uh there we go let me get that back up
sorry about that
uh so we have a question coming in here
from leo
and
he says when you have like a map and
reduce
and then that puts out an answer
so you have your functions going on and
you're doing your word count and then it
wants to have another one come in there
and grab that information and run it
as the input for the next one what kind
of tools do you use for that
uh sorry i didn't get the question can
you please repeat
okay so if you have two different
programs going
and the first one puts out an answer
and the second one needs to process that
answer so you have two completely
separate programs going how does uh
hadoop handle that what kind of tools do
you use to handle that
in hadoop you have to have you have to
have map to do a job chaining
there is a there is a there is a feature
in mapreduce called as job chaining
which slightly roundabout way of you
know changing jobs but you can configure
your map-reduce jobs in such a way that
you know one by one uh these jobs uh
these jobs are you know run one after
another so a simple answer answer to uh
answer to you would be uh like you know
you have to use something like something
like uh job chaining uh if you've been
reading books uh there is a book by the
name hadoop the definitive guide
chapter 11 of that book has an
explanation detailed explanation of how
hadoop job chaining can be done
see what i'm saying richard
yes okay excellent i might have to get a
copy of that book
it's an excellent book i tell you
let's see we have from uh riddim
i hope i'm saying that right uh
can't we go for python instead um
you you can do that and i i just today
afternoon i was talking to one of my
consulting clients and he asked me uh
about uh you know writing map reduce
programs in in in python and i told him
that because hadoop has got you know
something called as
something called as a
you know streaming api
which basically uh lets you write your
map reduce program in the language of
your choice and then it converts it into
map reduce so you can write your
programs in python uh and and i have a
lot of
you know examples when i take my class
they have a lot of examples in python
which i run using streaming uh api and
then that
streaming api converts your python
programs into mac reduce and then
ultimately magnitudes get run so uh to
answer your question i would say rhythm
uh you can write your programs in python
but there's an indirect way there's an
intermediate api in between that you
have to use if you have to use do it in
java then you can do it directly and
otherwise directly if you have to use
python you can use spark for it
so these are two three options that you
have available uh you know with them i
would say
excellent excellent yeah i'm actually
come from a programming background and
so i um have my use spark pi is one of
the main python interfaces which works
really good
by
so many of them
let's see let's see we still have a
couple more minutes on the polling and
then i have uh before i give you back
your screen let me go through some more
questions here
well this was a long one
the
sum of the question from arshia if i'm
getting this correctly is
going in and looking at
jobs so we go into indeed.com or
whatever
they're noticing that they're asking for
experience uh so getting started
learning all the big data getting their
certifications
what do you suggest for people so that
they can get that experience get those
initials set up
you know this is my favorite question i
keep answering it all the time
so i remember i i answered this last
time also
so arshia
the
the way i tell people is that if you can
see my screen right now
the way i tell people is that you know
when you go for a job interview have a
multi-node cluster setup on your machine
like this i have a hadoop multi-node
cluster setup and on this cluster on
this cluster have some three or four
data sets ready
and have some you know five or six use
cases ready
when you go for interviews
you while you're giving the interview
you can tell your like you know your
interviewer that you have you don't have
experience but you have got this much of
hands-on experience
on you know on hadoop and big data
write some implement some use cases uh
show your interviewer that you know
these are the use cases that you have
created
and then there is one more thing that
you can do you can ask that interviewer
if he has time he can give you a use
case and you can implement you you
should have the skills the knowledge and
you have if you i mean you'll have it
when you do courses like these you'll
have it you go ahead and implement that
use cases one or two hours that's the
most it is going to take right
i'm telling you if you follow this
strategy there is then i'm hardly seen
anybody who kind of you know rejects the
candidate because that is what they want
they want the person not to have like
you know okay you know there's a lot of
people who have got a lot of experience
but they don't have the knowledge
ultimately what matters is that whether
you have the skills to you know to hit
the ground running
and then you know whether you have the
experience in the technology or not that
becomes a material if you show them this
kind of setup where you've got
everything running up and live you know
executing in front of them with couple
of use cases
they cannot ignore you
right
yes that's what i'm finding and also not
only in there you have a blog up um and
i know if you post stuff to github
on my own groups i work with small
startup businesses
i've had three people says if you don't
have a getup hub a github
github
i can't speak suddenly
if you don't have an account
they don't even want to see it they want
to see examples of what you're doing
they want to be able to see what what
you're capable of
uh so yes i see that on there and having
the i'm having to be able to pull up the
virtual machine and show them real live
action what's going on yeah
yeah richard what you're saying is right
your github account with all the work
that you've done
uh your blog and and this kind of setup
these are the three things which can
kind of you know
really make make a selling point
for you i mean really positioning you
well for any kind of job what you're
saying is right
uh richard
excellent and then
i i myself am not familiar with devops
but i have a question on devops
compared to which is dependency on raw
data splunk and other factors
and for long term how does that compare
with the hadoop and data science setup
the
devops as a long-term solution
richard davox is more of an
infrastructure management tool so i tell
you what
um
and i have used to i used to work a lot
in this in my you know in my in my
projects when i was like you know a
full-time employee
uh with with multi-nationals uh what we
used to do was that you know for example
there is a tool called as uh you know
called as uh
you know continuous build environment um
you know hudson uh is is one of the
software so i think uh yeah so
what you call uh your thought ones are
the people behind began developing it
uh
it's more of an infrastructure
management type in a software so
yes uh let me just read that question
again um
quite a similarity including solution
data science in other ways no so devops
is more of
more of infrastructure management devop
is not going to do the processing for us
and prasad right it is not going to do
the processing for you here not it's not
only about storage it's about processing
your data well
so that you can do your business
analytics
devops is going to just kind of you know
do things like so as i was saying uh you
know you've got continuous build
environment you in that you can write
your rules whoever checks in i'm sure
you would know this whoever checks in uh
if he has compilation if his code has
compilation issues email is going to go
to all the you know what you call uh
you know all the stakeholders whoever
you have configured that you know
there's a goof up
right you can do those kind of things
you can have you know your page and
messages or sms's or you know what not
so that you build continuously keeps on
depending on the frequency that you have
set up continuous keep on keeps on
building
right so i would say it's it's it's it
they go hand in hand but in terms of
comparison it is chalk and cheese it is
apple and oranges right devops tools are
basically meant for a completely
different purpose that is infrastructure
management hadoop is meant for as you
would have understood from my definition
it is meant for managing and processing
big data it's a different ballgame
altogether i would say
richard
okay now now i know what devops is um
i'll have to read a little bit more on
that and
just so i have a deeper background
because i've never heard of devops
before i've never worked with it
oh it's one crazy telling selling
concept in the market right now richard
i guess i'm out of sync on that one
i i was working one of my organizations
where i was working as a chief learning
officer uh last year
uh for a couple of uh in a couple of
months i created a course in devops over
there so software there's software's
like chef puppet
jenkins so continuous building
environment is now called as jenkins
and yeah there's a whole lot of stories
so i would bore you with that but
there is
it's another field
altogether um
let's go and see i think we have time
for one more
question
um
hopefully i have time for this one where
is the temp data
when you're using the spark stored where
does that go
and how does that also sequence when
you're doing like the linked
data
data in in spark is basically in in
memory that is what makes it faster
you've got an option to have it
temporarily or caches it cache it as
well so that repeated runs of your job
can also produce the data
so it's basically in memory
and and you know it it runs in such a
you know performance efficient way on a
huge cluster which spark
will help you to kind of you know set up
for you
it basically does not allow you to you
know gives you the opportunity to do the
dump like mapper tools does it's in
memory all the computation is in memory
all the data is in memory and once the
computations of those you know chain of
jobs uh you know dag as i was saying
direct a cyclic
graph is done
you get the output either on hdfs or the
storage of your choice or back to your
spark context so these worker nodes
where your tasks are running they they
have the data in in memory richard
oops there we go okay
excellent and then um i'm just we have
like a minute left so um i have a news
asked a question what is cloudera
um and there's also i'm going to add in
hortons and cloud derricks those two
kind of go together they're similar but
oh yeah yeah i i yeah you know my
favorite questions i am i'm actually
going to uh
going to chennai uh next week to give a
presentation in in in a corporate on on
cloud era itself it's a five day
training
uh cloud era in hortonworks to basically
tell you the truth see what happens is
raw hadoop see hadoop is an open source
platform
and you know if you come across any
problem challenges you know in in
software project it does happen you come
across a situation where
you have hit a bottleneck you hit a
brick wall and you just don't know where
to go
so what uh you know there are certain
what what these guys have done is there
is
commercial players like cloud era like
hortonworks like mapar
what they do is that they provide uh uh
they provide uh
you know a specialized interface they
provide some specialized service over
and over for hadoop and what they also
say is that for a you know amc contract
for whatever you know duration that you
want
we'll provide you support as well so if
you come across a problem in setting up
cloud era or you're having any business
problem also we'll come and sit with you
and we'll solve it for you so to answer
this in one sentence i would say that
the commercial versions of hadoop
where you get support on a paid basis is
what is cloud data hortonworks and
mapper
okay so you basically you're setting up
a um
a service so that you have a phone call
away when you do run into problems
yeah and the person is going to come and
sit with you to solve it
that does wrap up our time for today
we have hit the end of the hour
if you have additional questions we do
have our forums at
community.simplylearn.com and you're
also welcome to email us
i'm going to go ahead and close a
session down thank you syed for joining
us today that was wonderful
thank you so much uh richard and thank
you so much all of you all for joining
the session and listening in
uh i wish you luck to all of you all uh
uh
that would be it from my side yep
richard
excellent all right thank you very much
happy learning and you have a good
evening morning or afternoon
thank you bye
you